raising your kids you got three sons
okay three sons and a daughter yeah oh
you have a daughter okay it only says
three sons you gotta updated yeah
pandemic baby
congratulations to you thank you we also
have four kids two two but going back to
it now that you have the kids it's
different to start versus where you want
to be once you have a family yeah why
not raise your family your kids in a in
a Muslim Nation rather than in the U.S
you have a choice right now just like
your mom and dad chose to say let's get
out of here let's go to a different
place I know your wife's a Christian so
you could say well my wife is a
Christian so it'd be tough to go to a
different place but why choose to raise
your kids in a judeo-christian
country like America why do that to
yourself why put yourself out of your
misery just go to a different place go
to Indonesia why be here well I don't
first of all I don't know if I would
think about it in those terms about like
you know raising them in a Christian
country as opposed to a Muslim country
as opposed to a Jewish country yeah what
I do is I raise them to be
multi-literate in all the languages all
the religious languages of the world
my kids understand both at a spiritual
level and and at a at an intellectual
level that religion is a language made
up of symbols and metaphors that us
communicating very similar sentiments
what matters is the sentiment I want you
to be spiritual I want you to know that
there is more to life than just what you
feel or smell or taste or see that there
is more and that you can access that
thing you can strive for Transcendence
and use your own means of doing it find
out what's most comfortable for you one
of my sons a few years ago after a very
raucous Rosh Hashanah celebration just
flat out declared himself Jewish was
like this is this is fun this is way
more fun than anything else that I've
done I want to be Jewish now and Rosh
Hashanah celebration yeah I've been to
many Rosh Hashanah celebrations I've
never been like this is the best party
I've ever done all that happens in honey
you could eat come to us buddy he said
he said it was raucous ones West
Hollywood yo West Hollywood
and uh and you know because for everyone
a couple years ago we went to Israel as
a family and the whole time he was like
my people I'm amongst my people
um I have another son who has uh I
bought him a um a kid's version of the
ramayana
which just blew his mind the idea that
God can be can exist in multiple avatars
and that each Avatar has a different
thing to it like this for strength and
for wisdom and for for power like that
so Hinduism he's all about Hinduism
right now I mean he radically believes
in reincarnation radically believes in
Karma
um I have another kid another boy who
I'm pretty sure is the reincarnated
Buddha but that's a whole different
story and we go to mosque we go to
church we go to synagogue we took our
kids on an 80-day Journey around the
world literally we circled the globe in
80 Days and went to ancient religious
places modern religious places
um it's great you know what's very
important if you want to raise spiritual
kids who aren't religious Fanatics teach
them about all religions they have the
ability in a way that adults whose minds
are fixated to differentiate between a
the external aspects of a religion and
the intern confuse the hell out of them
is your approach on the contrary it
confuses adults it makes perfect sense
to Kit it makes perfect sense to a 10
year old what kind of what kind of stuff
kids go to what kind of school do your
kids I mean they go to a nice private
school but no no like is it Christian
isn't Catholic is it a yes
secular so okay got it a 10 year old can
understand
intuitively that the rabbi and the Imam
and the priests are saying the same
thing they're just using different
symbols and the symbols even look kind
of familiar it's we we right here yeah
who can't figure that out like what do
you mean like they're different
religions to say different things they
have different ideas they like they read
different scriptures and you know they
they it's like but are they saying the
same thing though because
like I guess my question is like can all
religions be correct or can only one be
the correct religion remove the idea of
correct and incorrect right and wrong
when talking about religion they are
signposts all religions are signposts to
say that Christianity is more correct
than Islam is to say that French is more
correct than German
what the hell are you talking about it's
the thing that you are expressing
whether you say it in German or whether
you say it in French doesn't make it any
more correct
you're saying it's a means to an end and
the ends to an end okay religion so is
not an independent phenomenon religion
is an amalgamation a collection a system
of ways of thinking about the world many
of which has been constructed over
thousands of years and often very sort
of under control right by institutions
this is what it means and it can't mean
anything else
um yeah but I think that's the problem
is that nobody interprets it like that
like that's actually a great way of
looking at it whether it's like like how
you use the example of I'd rather dig
one six foot
well for to reach the water versus six
one foot Wells I can appreciate that
here's what I would say is you think
that nobody interprets it that way
because people are not as conscious of
it 2 . two-thirds of American Catholics
believe uh or disagree with the Catholic
church when it comes to abortion and
lgbtq rights but they call themselves
Catholic
but wait a minute abortion lgbtq those
are like fairly set things in the
Catholic church it's like you believe
this if you want to be with us well I
want to be with you but I don't believe
those things
and there's no contradiction there it
doesn't doesn't stay up all night
thinking about these things they don't
write books about it they don't come on
podcasts and talk about what that
actually means for two hours it just is
and that's true for all religious people
I think a lot of unreligious people
people outside of religion
you know the the Dawkins and the
harrises and the and the you know uh
Hitchens believe that religious people
are like automatons right they're like
the old-fashioned
um you know IBM computers right you
remember the the little sheet with the
dots on it and stuff that that's that's
what scripture is that it's like we're
an automaton and the scripture is the
program and the scripture you read the
scripture and it goes and you do the
thing in the scripture that's not how it
works man
that's not how it works scripture
without interpretation is just words on
a page it requires an individual to
encounter it for it to have any meaning
at all and by definition
the minute an individual encounters that
scripture it goes through the filter of
his entire experience his entire
identity and it comes out different on
the other side that's why two people
can go to the exact same scripture and
walk away with two radically different
points of view in American history not
two centuries ago both slave owners and
abolitionists not only use the same
scripture in order to justify their
viewpoints they use the same exact
verses right
that's what scripture you know you know
I got to tell you so a couple things
very interesting point I agree somebody
can go watch a movie and have yesterday
I was telling the kids I said hey how is
it that both of you guys are the same
parents yet you're two completely
opposite people right they're the same
things being taught you're taking two
different messaging there's a part of
that that's correct I have twins so yeah
but there's a part of it as well as on
how
it's being taught messaging received all
of that part of it is on the person's
individual personality so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]